non-minimalists
how do we teach our children to politely
accept
compliments on clothing but not use
fashion as social status
or a bonding mechanism so speaking of
high school yeah
wow and so um you know i haven't faced
this yet my daughter's only seven and
she loves wearing a gucci purse you're
right
[Laughter]
and i will strangle the life out of you
um
no she she loves wearing like real flowy
dresses so like everything is just
functional for her like she'll go
rock climbing in a dress yeah because
she she likes nature
and she likes dresses and i think in a
way it's almost like we need to get back
to that
that childhood mindset of like is this
appropriate
for what i'm doing and do i enjoy it
and now as parents we have to steer elle
in the right direction like hey young
lady go put some underwear on
um but but also
there is this time where kids do start
to get their identity their social
status
and we talked about this a few weeks ago
ryan we had the guy from preachers and
sneakers are you familiar with this
account
okay so it's uh i saw the episode though
okay yeah
yeah yeah so he uh um he the reason he
had the sneaker over his face is he's
still
anonymous like he has to be anonymous
for now he's gotten death threats and a
bunch of others
giving him death threats yeah i mean
um which which is weird because like
what i love is
he's turned his these comments his
comment section on on instagram it's
just at preachers and sneakers check it
out
so what he started doing was he realized
because he's like he's a christian
and and he was like i'm uh he's going to
church and he felt like
he he felt conflicted because he saw
that there were like some pastors
wearing like
a thousand dollar fear of god sneakers
and it was like wait a minute like i'm
giving my money to the church and so all
he did is he started this instagram
account just for his friends
and he would take a picture of the
person already posted online so that
it was already there it was a preacher
and they would have you know it was like
chadveech or something
and he'd be wearing 700 gucci
uh shoes and he would just put a
snapshot
from the website like stockx or whatever
website those shoes were on
and he would say no commentary like it
was just
here's the preacher here is the the
sneakers they're wearing
yeah and um ryan and i had a whole
you know discussion and and i was trying
to be charitable to what they were doing
and we we
we had a whole sort of um debate around
around that and so i'm not going to
rehash that debate but what i'll say
is that often our fashion
we try to use that as a shortcut toward
our
relationships but of course there aren't
shortcuts because if you just put a
facade on a rotting house the house is
still going to fall apart
if you are nothing beneath the fashion
then even with the fashion you're still
nothing you still have nothing to
contribute
until you have something to contribute
there's something there like
you know your fashion should strengthen
your relationships not be
your relationships and i think i mean i
look back at high school when
tommy hilfiger was cool actually it was
cool again for a minute yeah
about six months right a couple years
ago but uh
but yeah i mean i i went out of my way
to wear certain brands
thinking that that was gonna make me a
cool kid and maybe i
looked cool 90s yeah maybe i look cool
but what made me cool was me
i was i was a cool person tell them josh
no uh yeah how do you get a kid though
to like not look at those brand names to
be
oh you know i don't know the answer to
that because
because if i had kids i certainly
wouldn't just
buy them every brand name that they
wanted i would encourage them like hey
look if you want to
own a pair of gucci sneakers like you're
going to have to work to get those
so i wouldn't discourage them right from
working hard and buying something that
they want
um but i also wouldn't just give it to i
don't know i don't know
i think so i i actually did that so
remember i mean i i dressed really well
in high school
i spent an absurd amount of my own money
you know we we grew up really poor but
then by the time i was 14 i was able to
get a job
and and so everyone's making 425 an hour
i was like this is more money than i'll
ever need
and and uh at the end of the summer i
had all this money saved
i just went to the mall and bought
clothes with it yeah and and so
i think it's okay if your kid wants to
go out and earn
the money to buy their own clothes but
here's what i wish would have happened i
wish it would have been a way to
communicate with me at the time
that hey you're going to buy some of
these
things but why are you buying it and i
think quite often we're not asking
kids these questions and actually making
them explain
themselves why why are you buying this
yeah who are you buying this for
right and not in a way that's accusatory
or judging
but in a way that that is actually
inquisitive
because we we need to be able to ask
those same questions of ourselves right
and so what behavior are you modeling
for your kids
as well you can be stylish without brand
names without
logos in fact have you talked to your
kid about
well are you paying
for the privilege of advertising for
that corporation for tommy hilfiger or
nike or whoever
or are they paying you well the answer
is obvious they
they should be paying you wearing a
giant logo of a horse on your shirt or
whatever
yeah but but the truth is you're
paying them for the privilege of being a
walking billboard for that company
are you being used and manipulated by
that company
and oh you're wearing it because your
other friends are wearing well why are
your other friends wearing it and so
we start asking these questions we get
to the why and then the why behind the
why
all of a sudden it doesn't mean it's
going to change their behavior or their
desires necessarily
but it might make them think differently
about how they're going to spend their
money on those things
ron do you have any advice for your
former self like when you think about
the clothes you had with tags on it
the sneakers like is there anything you
think you could have told yourself back
then to help you
prevent from buying that because i'm
trying that's what i'm asking myself
right now i
honestly know i think i just had to go
through it yeah be completely honest
and to be honest with myself as well
because there were times where i went
out
to buy just say i was going to hang out
with friends and i wanted to buy some
just to hang out with friends
and and me standing here and being able
to admit that honestly
sounds crazy but it's true you know i
would i would go out and say
you know i'll go buy a new pair of jeans
just to wear this day because i don't
like the jeans i already had
yeah and that's how i ended up with
things with tags one of my things i want
to wear once
and you know buying shoes because
somebody else had these pair of shoes
and i wore them once and they sat in the
box so i i think
there's nothing i could have said
because i had to learn it on my own yeah
you know
my dad would tell me all the time
various life lessons um he would always
tell me
remember who you are and who you are and
um and in various other
statements he would tell me my brother
but
regardless of those life lessons he
taught us we still had to experience
things to learn them
so i think i had to go through that to
to figure it out for myself in some
cases
i mean that might be the best answer
yeah it's like let your kid go through
it
yeah i mean the only thing they only
still ask those questions of course
because if they still go through it they
may start asking
the questions of themselves sooner if
they're exposed to
this alternate point of view this this
yeah if they're exposed to the truth so
i guess what i'm saying is
after you kind of give your kids this
wisdom
it's up to them whether or not they want
to use it i mean your job as a parent to
set boundaries is to impart your wisdom
on them but ultimately yeah sometimes
they're going to have to go through it i
think the other question i'd add
i would also or have my child ask
is if you didn't own these clothes would
your friends still be your friends yep
because i think maybe that might have
maybe done something for me when i was
in high school but i i kind of look at
it like you do ron like in high school i
don't think
it doesn't matter what you would have
told me and they're like no i'm going to
spend 120
on these tommy hilfiger jeans because
that's what everyone else is wearing
yeah but the truth is that your friends
would have been your friend
absolutely and you know i think about
you know our little group we
we there was four of us um me
and jerome my brother and then ryan and
his best friend pacho
and we looked like a harvard diversity
poster
and and and so like there there was
there was the four of us
and like yeah jerome was probably by
default the coolest of the group
yeah but he never wore uh he didn't care
about brand he would often wear mine
he never cared about it he wore
he wore like like baggy t-shirts from uh
walmart or big bear or wherever get away
with that because he could kick anyone's
ass
right yeah that's just true but my point
is that like
that's actually what cool used to be
when you go back look at the rolling
stones you couldn't say what
brand of anything they were like the
super they were
the cool peer people of their period
right and you move forward
and even you you look at early hip hop
culture
you can go and figure out what the
brands were it wasn't until very
recently
that we we started valuing brands
and branding i mean think about that
term branding
yeah that's what we do to cattle
and yet we're doing it to ourselves
um there's a new jack harlow song i used
to really like jack harlow but i don't
like him anymore um
why not why just his new his music the
first album was amazing he's his first
he has this album called gazebo which
he's from louisville kentucky
dude it's matt carney's thing where you
got your whole life to write your first
album yeah yeah
it's a it's a perfect classic album
underground no one's heard it
um and uh and then he like just started
taking on the new waves he has this line
and this this new song of his um talking
about how he got the shoe deal with new
balance and now i'll do anything that
new balance says and i'm like
that's the problem right you're putting
a
brand in your song and you're also
saying i will do it anything oh oh so
they're
they're your master now i'll do anything
does he intend that as a lesson or is he
like
no it's a brag i was trying to be a
humble brag i'm like uh that's the wrong
brag buddy
interesting yeah oh you are a shill for
a corporation
congratulations yeah wow yeah and so i
don't feel
i i i i i look at anyone who
embodied cool previous to recently
and and there was it was never about the
clothing they wore
the clothing was cool because of the
person who was wearing it the person
wasn't cool because of the clothes they
were wearing